Being a human can be confusing.
It can be hard to understand who you are and
why you do the things you do.
Hard to feel good about yourself when you
live with all of your flaws and afflictions.
Hard to feel important in a world with others
who have their own sets of problems, often
too preoccupied with their own to care about
yours.
And more often than not, because of all this,
it can feel like you are all alone.
When we feel like this, it can be very easy
to lose our belief in love.
To feel as though we do not deserve it.
We might find ourselves subconsciously sabotaging
or pushing love away every time we get close
enough to touch it.
Because not until we learn that we are all
inherently worthy of love, and are able to
love ourselves unconditionally, will we ever
be able to accept love from someone else.
And not until we accept love from someone
else, will someone else ever be able to truly
love us and make us feel a little less alone.
Learning how to love yourself allows you to
understand what love really is and how it
works.
Loving yourself does not mean that you think
you’re better than others.
It does not mean that you are always happy.
And it does not mean that you think you are
perfect.
It means that you know your flaws and struggles,
but still value and appreciate who you are,
what you have, and your efforts to do the
best you can and make the most of life, despite
it all.
When you understand this for yourself, you
understand that the same applies to loving
someone else.
You understand how to both give love and accept
love.
The truth is, we don’t need any permission
or achievement to be worthy of love.
We are all alive and regardless of where we
came from and what we have done or gone through,
being alive is the only permission you need
to feel like you are worthy of being alive.
The inability to love one’s own self and
embrace the unconditional premise of love
is one of the biggest reasons why people struggle
to find and sustain successful relationships.
It is why a person might get irritated by
the subtlest of their partner’s quirks.
Why couples might fight over silly, trivial
things.
Why couples distance over time or leave out
important parts of who they are and what they
want in life.
Why one might betray the other and have an
affair.
Or why when the initial lustfulness of a relationship
goes away, often the love dies with it.
All because one or both individuals don’t
understand and believe that they are worthy
of love and therefore, they act out of the
insecurity and desperation that the void of
love creates.
You simply cannot give someone something that
you do not have, and you cannot accept something
that you do not believe in from someone else.
If you do not have love for the self, you
do not have any love to give to someone else.
And, if you do not believe you are worthy
of love, you will resist anyone’s attempt
to give you theirs.
You will think that a person who claims to
love you must be deceitful or crazy.
Or just hasn’t had enough of a chance to
see you for who you truly are.
But perhaps they have.
Perhaps you are the one who hasn’t seen
yourself for who you truly are.